let's talk about this book too busy to
die okay too busy to die which is just a
great it's a great motto you don't have
time for that nonsense right no as a
matter of fact that came about because I
had finished three autobiographies I I
remember meeting me me I remember me I
just remembered what I forgot to
remember yeah and I said to Mel Brooks
what do I do now he says write another
book too busy to die busy to die and so
I I I wrote this which is about my life
from the time I was six years old every
performance thing I did from being cast
in kindergarteners in six who passed
while the lentils boil you remember that
but oh yeah that's a that's a big one
with the Irish yeah I played the
headsman my mother sat next to a mr.
Scapa who was the prayer of the
principal and he said to her that boy is
the best one and for the rest of my life
my mother any time she saw me in
anything you were the best one oh oh
that's so sweet you know we have a
picture it's in the book a picture of
you with your mom I love this photograph
that's a fantastic I don't know why you
didn't stick with that hair if I could
have you know my mother every death well
she always said that but she had one
complaint yeah and when I did the show a
show she said you were the best one but
they didn't give you enough to do oh no
really this that's the mom always likes
to give a little dig in there don't they
you know what I was looking at that
picture of you as a young lad and I
thought you look I don't know if you
watched Game of Thrones if you look just
like bran from Game of Thrones
so the remarkable resemblance there you
should get a cut of that show I'm just
saying you should get a cut of that show
you